holiday shopping season is here and we
have some CBS mornings deals that can
make great gifts for your family or for
you all at exclusive low prices to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen right now or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Elizabeth
Warner is here good morning let's kick
this off so this is a technology driven
world you have a power bank charger yeah
so think about the last time you lost
power with your phone or your kids did
right right you can't call anyone you
can't get anywhere GPS so these Chargers
are amazing the rush Chargers these
actually charge your phone you just plug
them directly in so we have no cables
easy to use and they'll give you an
extra 30 hours of talk time the Trident
I love because it's got a jack for
absolutely anything so no matter what
phone you have what device you have
these are amazing take them with you in
the car in your purse in your bag you
should never be without power how much
yes so right now these are up to 45 off
and starting at as low as 34.99 amazing
yeah that's a lifestyle don't leave home
without it
okay so this is the brella shade I'm
going to hand it to you open it up this
is for the inside of your car so we all
know that hot day hot day you go into
the car right your car is sweltering you
put this into your front windshield you
use the uh sun shades to hold it in
place it's going to bring the
temperature of your car down 35 degrees
and protect the inside of your car we
today are doing a set of two of these 40
off 23.99 oh that's a good deal my
wife's from Arizona keep one so I know
what it's like to get in a hot car and
burn it back oh remember the seat you
stick to the seats yeah yes
all right beloved bath this is an
amazing company so two moms uh Pat and
Pam they met 20 years ago they both have
children that have autism and they used
to make lavender bath products at home
because it sued their kids they realized
as the kids were growing that they were
going to need employment along with many
other people with Autism so they
actually created a company and this
company makes you'll see the candle
beautiful lotion yes soap all in
lavender and these are beautifully made
by people with Autism so it gives them
an opportunity and empowers them
supporting a great brand great and also
you get to relax at home that's right
give this as a gift somebody's going to
love you so beloved bath this is uh
42.40 an amazing amazing savings and you
get the whole set all right so I've been
staring at this all I know you're
excited okay raycon go ahead put those
on you might know ready J oh yeah okay
yeah so it comes as musical himself
obviously comes from a musical family we
know his sister Brandy of course of
course it's Snoop Dogg so wanted Quality
quality and wanted to bring quality
headphones that were affordable and
accessible to all of us these are
designed for gaming but you can use them
for music as well inside of each ear
there's double speakers you get surround
sound it's got the um vibration haptics
so you're gonna actually feel you feel
what you see in the game it's really
amazing so from head to toe it's got
lights on the outside you can adjust
volume and this is retractable that
that's retractable isn't that neat
pop it in and just use it to listen to
music absolutely whether you have a
Skype calls whatever you're going to use
you can use it for all of it all right
but what's the price though because
headphones can get really exciting right
and Tech is so hot right for Christmas
time
times are amazing they are a special
price today of 80
dollars
under a hundred dollars for this type of
quality you can't find that anywhere and
you know what it is though there's
weight to it so I know their quality and
they're extremely comfortable studio
quality yes the foam all right you're
going to wear these when you play with
your son I like it of course
I wonder we appreciate you thank you so
much and of course with all of these
companies to get these deals to buy
anything that you saw in the other stuff
scan the QR code on your screen right
now or head over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now